hey guys it's Justine as you know I am a
huge Apple fan and many of you guys have
been like Justine talk about the gates
talk about buta gate talk about charge
gate I'm gonna talk about it I'm not
sure what you mean just to say about it
other than my front-facing camera makes
me look beautiful and I don't have a
problem with charge gate my phone
charges perfectly fine now I'm not
saying that these aren't issues what at
least my phone isn't exploding or
catching on fire that's all I'm saying
crossing our fingers that that doesn't
happen to anybody no matter what type of
phone you're using anyway it's been
about two weeks since I got my phone and
I still love it
I also am a huge samsung fan I love my
Google pixel I love phones I love
technology and I tend to gravitate
towards apples I am a big I phone fan
but that's not to say that I don't enjoy
other phones I'd like Android I prefer
iOS and guess what so do a lot of other
people the thing is Android is on so
many phones that it's kind of hard to
get one sort of experience on it whereas
iOS is only on one device so I don't
know where I'm going with this I just
like trying to get all the Android
fanboys all fired up and angry and
leaving angry comments because I think
it's it's funny actually the the
fighting in the comments that happens
about Mac first PC first Android first
iOS people can use whatever they want
it's not really that big of a deal there
are preferences if everyone likes the
same thing this world would be
incredibly boring so if you would say oh
I also filmed a photo test video and a
video test video which I never even
ended up posting I got so overwhelmed
shooting so many iPhone videos that by
the time it came to start editing the
photo and video review video with the
iPhone 10 the iPhone 10's Macs and the
note 9 I was like I can't do this right
now so I just did it and I figured that
I would take some of that footage and
content and put it into another video so
that's the video that you guys are
watching right now so I'm not sure if
it's safe to say that Beauty gate is a
filter because I don't think anyone has
really come out with what exactly it is
I read a few articles there's one that
is saying that it's the noise reduction
but when I initially took that photo I
was kind of thinking it was the smart
HDR these basically what it felt like it
was doing was it
pulling out all of the shadows so it was
kind of just making a very evenly lit
photo okay I want to show you a
difference between selfies
oh you look bad there hey I think you
look beautiful
well no because they are because it yeah
he's out the contrasts and everything
look look at that that looks really good
right wow I'm impressed
I'm very impressed me too very neat yeah
it looks great
one looks more in person don't answer
the question do you guys want to go to
book a Tibet Bo tonight with someone
please go to Bhutan a Beppo with me
anyway let's carry on with the camera
test today we're gonna be testing out
the photo and video from the iPhone and
tennis max the note 9 and the iPhone 10
we're at the beach it's really really
hot and really really bright hopefully
we can get some photos they did say that
they have tested out the new iPhone
China in salt water conditions that I
don't want to do that guys a little bit
Rick setup so we have to subtract lot
Jenna has got all three phones and she's
about to do the first photo test the
first thing that we're gonna do is we're
just gonna take straight normal pictures
nothing crazy
no portrait effect no live focus on the
Samsung Note nine just a normal freaking
picture sure that's alright no I'm not
[Music]
now do a portrait mode one and live
focus on the same side here
we'll have the Sun facing my back
there's bugs flying all around me act
out the crypts the crawling through the
cracks my shirt so I'm just gonna take a
few pictures of just the scenery and get
a pair of those
[Music]
you look like an angel this one is alive
I don't even know if I can all be in all
of these shots okay just for my own
reference of editing this is iPhone 1010
s max this is no hello you got all three
of our cameras here you move around a
little
okay how about this
think that I'm in all the frames so
we're just gonna take a slow little walk
over here
move around a little bit
we left our friends eating cats
[Music]
another thing that I've noticed is it
does autofocus way faster so we're gonna
see how long it takes to focus on the
bag this is a bad test and if you don't
want to take my word for it hey there's
still more to this video so let's go
take some more pictures now we're giving
out the rear video and all three of
these phones so let's get up real close
real personal iPhone 10's max Samsung
Galaxy Note 9 and the iPhone hen iPhone
10s max Samsung Galaxy Note 9 and the
iPhone 10 which one looks best
which one what's the best record record
hello everyone this here is the iPhone
10 this is the note and this here is the
new iPhone 10's max the stereo let's try
that out on me iPhone tennis so here I
am the stereo recording alright which
one do you think looks the best iPhone
tennis max the Samsung Galaxy Note 9 or
the iPhone 10 what do you think think
about it I'm gonna put a pole right here
so a lot of you guys have been asking me
if I've been affected by charge gate so
charge gate is affecting some phones
where the display isn't on so the phone
is asleep and you plug it in and
normally that should start charging but
it's not it's just not doing anything
but it will start charging if you tap
the screen turn it on wake it up I don't
have that problem I'm gonna just double
check let's try it just to see cord is
here plug it in okay it's charging let's
try it again
phone is off plugging it in it's
charging phone is locked and it's
charging okay well I don't have charge
gate the thing that I've been real
freaking out about is getting use to the
big phone again this phone it's huge
like the screen is massive which I
absolutely love having this much screen
real estate the one thing that I do miss
is the previous version of the iPhone
tennis and attend a perfect sized phone
to fit in yoga pants my sister and I do
a lot of hikes so this phone is just
slightly a little bit too big for the
pockets of my yoga pants so he's just
like sticking out on the top whereas the
previous version was it was the perfect
size so really that's sort of been the
only issue that has been a little bit of
a struggle for me it's trying to figure
out do I want to keep the bigger phone
or do I want the smaller one but then I
went back to using the smaller phone and
having this much screen thick this thing
just looks so beautiful and so crisp
that I don't really want to switch back
to the smaller phone
I know these are dumb and iJustine first
world problems
this is my channel and this is my video
and you guys know that I'm an Apple fan
and I make a lot of videos about iPhones
so I don't think that I need to justify
my issues do i I've definitely noticed
that my battery life has been a lot
better usually by like five or six
o'clock I feel like my phone is
completely dead and I would never leave
the house
not even to walk the dog without having
a movi with me so I do feel like I can
probably make it until about like nine
or ten all right so I'm gonna make a
quick little video because all of you
guys have been tweeting me and freaking
out about the beauty gates and the
charge gates and all the gates and I
just thought that I should probably
address it because you I honestly have
just been super busy doing other things
and I have not had time to make a video
about it here here it is I'm talking
about it I think you negate I love
beauty gate maybe it was the iPhone pen
that wasn't realistic it maybe this is
what I really look like I'm not sure but
either way the photos and video that I
have been getting from the iPhone have
been so amazing I did an entire vlog
traveling to London if you guys want to
see that I'll put a link in the
description and an annotation so you
guys can see the full range of what this
camera is really capable of doing on a
daily basis a lot of you guys that said
just you know is this phone something
that I can vlog on yes it is the audio
is even really good I shot half of that
iPhone 10's video in stereo and the
other half not in stereo so that I could
kind of do a test it was more a test for
myself but I don't even think I
mentioned in the video that I did that
so if you do go and watch that watch
with that in mind and see if you guys
can tell when I turn the stereo off and
when it was on well thank you guys for
watching if you did make it this far in
the video I appreciate it I had so much
fun making all of the iPhone videos
during an iPhone week my sister and I
spent a lot of time shooting those and I
spent so much time editing that I felt
like at some point I was like oh I got
to stop I posted so many iPhone videos I
just need a small little break so now
that that break is over hello I'm back I
do want to make a small little promise
you guys that I will start posting more
vlogs not like a lot but maybe more than
I don't know once every three months I
felt like there was a point where
vlogging wasn't fun anymore and it
became a forced activity so since I've
taken some time away from it when I went
to London I was like wow I really
actually missed vlogging and telling a
story and editing vlogs I will see you
guys in my next video if you guys aren't
already subscribed please do so
hit the bell so you'll be notified when
I post new videos and I would love to
hear from you guys in the comments below
are you an Android fan are you an iOS
fan do you not really care I can't even
tell you how much Jenna and I have been
using walkie talkie hey I'm just telling
the Internet how much we love walkie
talkie okay well I think she's
unavailable
she really ruined this video segment
okay I'm gonna go I'm just rambling at
this point so I'll see you guys in the
next video bye
[Music]